hey no problem ain't nobody gonna stop
the boogie buzz hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome back to turbo
dismount I don't know I miss this pose
but there's been two updates to this
game since the last time that I played
it so it's gonna get pretty interesting
boggle up or down cuz I'd be defeating
the point of turbo dismount haha
something tells me this ain't gonna do
oh my goodness oh Jesus
oh my god how did I dodge every single
one of those bastards oh well I just
love the rhythmic undulation of the
boogie bus because the boogie bus is
obviously for stuff and things
okay can we hit one could we hit one
place one thank you oh well it's amazing
how not many of these I hit do you like
that me do you like humping the boogie
bust me oh you're such a rapscallion you
so confident Morgan Morgan Wow I think
the problem with the other one was that
it was a little too ow yep okay this
seems to be oh hey oh cool all right
what happened
tell me right here tell me right how's
it oh oh I'm the head on the crowd okay
my head get all the way out here hello
beautiful goodbye beautiful tell me what
the hell happened to you I'm gonna make
a damn bit of sense okay so well the
question of the day is why they added
this okay I got you
Oh ain't you just the most adorable
little evil I'm putting you on the
boogie bus god damn you're so cute well
that's weird okay
well alright then I saw hilarious as I
was hoping for well okay then
you know let's cleared it out of the
death box but nope too late for you my
grundle
my poor grundle there we go I don't know
why that's so hilarious but it is cool I
forgot that my mouse was recording that
whole time so it's probably annoying
great miss Baum we'll be getting down
dirty
I know hottie who is so provocative in
sex okay all right
that's something so ridiculous about
seeing that body with a skull face this
is why the boogie buses may have some
favorite vehicle oh I've ever loved a
vehicle more than the boogie bus for
moral reasons Oh behind by boogie bus
I'll just okay you're gonna wait for me
great ah it's awesome praise be the
boogie bus the booty bounce she'll lead
us off to safety or something I don't
know let's just go word must bobbin go I
think I found and we're dead there's the
remnants of another boogie bus here but
my gorilla my grim gorilla - sure love
this one boss don't know about this [ __ ]
at least dad ass was nice before it
happened it seems it's on a sub who I
made a terrible decision Oh what
happened
it said improve lots of fun I'm
beginning to think where did I go
exploded
don't ask I've been doing this for like
five minutes you bested me up I have no
reason for doing this shut up go away
don't judge me all right I think that's
enough death for one day thank you so
much for watching turbo dismount I'll
play it again when there's another
update or if there's enough demand for
it so thanks again check out the other
videos at turbo dismount that I played
in another exploding games down the
description below thanks again everybody
and as always I will see in the next
video not exactly what we're going for
you